welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we want to
study space-time diagrams a little bit
more in detail and also define certain
regions in space-time diagrams
so let's start again with you know
alice's space-time diagram here in which
we plot
or draw bob's base time diagram the
relative velocity difference is 0.5
times the speed of light and it
leads to a gamma factor of 1.2
we also plotted
the word line of light in here in yellow
light with a speed of light equal to c
and i want to discuss two specific
events the first one here event number
one
is the one where
um
t a the time for for alice is one
and xb
the space for bob is equal to zero so
this event lies on bob's timeline
if we read off the time
on bob's clock we see it's 0.83 one over
gamma and here we can immediately lead
read off time dilation for this event
note that
while xb for bob is equal to zero
x a for alice is not
zero similarly we can look at the second
event here where
we read off x a equal one
we don't one in this case light year for
alice
and so now we want to investigate this
length
in bob's reference frame
for for him time is equal to zero so t b
equals zero we can immediately again
read off xb
equal
0.83 and that indicates length
contraction as of the above
important to note here is that those two
alice and bob will not agree on the time
when the measurement was made
all right so let's zoom out here a
little bit
um
and look at another space-time diagram
so in this space-time diagram again i
drew light
word lines or word lines for light
in yellow
and i plotted a total of 12 different
events
and now we want to characterize those
events and we're going to characterize
them based on whether or not they are
time-like
light-like or space-like
as time-like we define those events
where c square
t-square minus x-square is greater than
zero
light-like are those which are like
light in a word line
ct
c square t square minus x square equal
to zero and space like those where
c square t square minus x square is
smaller than zero
so the first task is now to find
to which of those
regions the individual events correspond
and so again stop it stop the video and
and try to figure out whether or not you
can find the solutions
so the solutions are given here time
like are events
two
five and six light like other ones which
lie on the yellow lines one seven four
and nine
and space like are 8 12
11 10 and 3.
so one of the things you can find if you
if you um
you know starting here in the origin
and you want to correspond to any event
in the future
you can only do that if the events are
time-like
if the events are space-like you will
not be able to correspond between those
two events
that's one of the way to to read
the the this kind of space-time diagram
and in the next section in the next
video we'll talk about causality
meaning can a specific event cause
something to happen in another event
again this can only happen if the events
are actually time-like
you